Here, the hypotenuse is 30 inches. Great work if you found this number. We'll
start with a right triangle, with side lengths 18 inches and 24 inches. We'll
use x for the length of the hypotenuse since that's what we're finding. Now we
just plug into the Pythagorean theorem, squaring the legs, and squaring our
unknown hypotenuse length. When we square 18, we get 324. And when we square
24, we get 576. The sum of these equals 900. And no we can take the square root
of both sides to solve for x. Here, we'll keep the positive root only, since
we're talking about distance. The length that this hypotenuse is 30 inches.
This triangle is actually a special right triangle with side lengths in the
ratio of 3 to 4 to 5. So, we can actually use this to help us solve for x
without using the Pythagorean Theorem. If we multiply 3 by 6, we'll get 18. And
if we multiple 4 by 6 we'll get 24. This means to find this unknown hypotneuse
we multiple the hypotneuse by 5 by our same multipler 6. We multiple 5 times 6
we'll get 30. Now not every right triangle will be so special. In this case it
was since these side lengths were in the ratio of 3 to 4 to 5. This is why we
looked at those Pythagorean triples earlier. Sometimes they can help us problem
solve more quickly. But either way we solve we'll still get a hypotenuse of 30.